he might get leapfrogged into second
place if he doesn't win uh if ferugia
takes his match so prague still has a
lot to play for
even if magnus has won the tournament
and magnus goes back to an opening he
was playing earlier this week and he's
just asking to play the french defense
so he's
at least saying okay i'm very flexible
here
pragnanda does not take up the challenge
and push the white king's pawn forward
instead we see a check
very solid stuff are we going to see
bishop bishop oh we are
and uh yeah wow simon
[Music]
what do you think about this move
brilliant
best move ever f for forward pushing the
f-pawn and the reason you're so happy
simon uh for the viewers is it's almost
a dutch defense now
yeah pretty pretty much i mean without
dark square bishops uh i'm never really
sure if that who that favors so much i
mean
i i would have thought now
there's a couple of different variations
in the dutch you can play as black and
magnus has been a bit of a fan of the
stone wall dutch in the past but you
don't want to do that after exchanging
those bishops you'd probably try to go
for a more
classical dutch setup which is my
favorite
uh opening and
you can also see maybe black trying to
fianchetto now his light square bishop
this would be a very standard idea to
play a couple of yeah so that okay he's
going for classical dutch happy to see
this he's been watching your game simon
oh god i hope not because that's not
going to help him that much in life
um and i mean the idea here is is to
push the pawn in front of black's king
at some moment and
take the center like that um maybe even
now
maybe even now why not yeah why not push
it now this is the main idea and uh it's
uh yeah i mean
we'll see so i'm happy to see this
because you very rarely see this set up
uh at the top levels nowadays so yeah
yeah looks like a good version black i
mean he's traded off one set of pawn uh
one set of pieces sorry the black king
can castle
um prague really needs to start castling
early i think that's maybe one of his
mistakes this final against magnus
and uh yeah black can get his king to
safety okay he does occupy the center
first typical idea yeah very typical
idea those those two black pawns are one
of the reasons you play this this
opening um they can look after each
other control a lot of squares and if
black can castle and at least develop
the queen side knight then it should be
a comfortable position for black black
has chances to attack on the king's side
later on but obviously white's very
solid as well so white white is is by no
means worse so we say i was just going
to say you know do you think that prague
you know also being in a must-win
situation if he wants to keep this match
alive do you think he was going to
castle his king to the left
he's keeping his options open yeah yeah
exactly and
well magnus is really intent on
determining the pawn center and he's
asking prague are you going to step your
pawn forward are you going to make some
trades what you're going to do
interesting move that one
i mean that would be my first fault and
uh i think yeah i think he's trying to
close it down as well possibly magnus
with the knight maybe developing behind
that pawn
and just trying to define the pawn
structure and here we go prague has now
defined the pawn structure already um
which i'm a bit sad to see that move i
really wanted to see prague castle to
the left i think that's his idea ivanka
i still do that yeah i think it's more
likely to castle this way than the other
way right now
magnus pushes even further gaining all
the space possible and i guess he wants
to use this square for the black knight
nice outpost in the middle of the board
he has indeed brought his knight forward
it's all about whether white at some
point can undermine the head of the
black pawn chain if you let this pawn
kind of sit in your camp for too long
you'll just get smothered you'll just
run out of space yeah
and uh definitely you need to start
doing that uh you can also do it by uh
picking up the h pawn and pushing
g the g pawn two squares forward
this one you need a lot of preparation
work though uh very very weakening for
white so yeah i'm expecting prague now
to make his decision which side to
castle
and uh once he's decided then we'll know
what pawn pushes he's going for if he
castles this way for sure he's going to
go for like this one or as your anchor
mentioned at some point just breaking
out uh throwing pawns towards the black
king which is nearly definitely going to
go this way or you would think so i
really hope we see that that move on the
board because also black's going to
sacrifice pawn with a typical break if
that happens later on
and it will just be king on king action
um in in that position so that type king
on king yeah yeah
yeah the white king is going to sit on
the opposite side to the black king and
um due to this imbalance black will
throw pawns forward on this side as
simon mentions black black will kind of
sacrifice a pawn most likely here white
might do the same on the other flank and
it will just be a race it'll be
fireworks for us
and the two players will end on a high
but okay it's up to prague if you want a
slower kind of game you could still
castle this side it's just a bit more
scary that you might walk into an attack
later on um if you cast them on this
side of the board you could see not
right now but later for example the
night come out the queen come out
and some ideas against the white king
yep seems like a pretty decent position
for magnus i i guess here but it's
always a bit risky playing the dutch
i'll be honest you know
you are committing your pawns to go
forwards
at very early stage so uh should come a
bit of a health warning and uh
you don't you know prague just doesn't
like castling this is one thing i've
learned he's like would i okay that's a
that's very interesting exchange because
he has swapped off that maybe bad bishop
for a night i mean
i wouldn't have thought about that that
bishop had great potential in the long
run maybe not in the short run but in
the long run
uh so i don't know what you think of
that exchange it's quite a strange one
really mixed feelings i mean i guess his
his kind of rationale is that it's a
block center nicer better in general
more flexible when the center is blocked
but you're right simon that white light
squared bishop it controls some key
squares
and also it costs two tempe
often if you have to move a piece around
quite a lot white's bishop moved four
times there before swapping itself off
yeah it just feels like you're losing
time and that that one or two moves that
you're spending losing wasting i mean
they could come back to want you yeah
i mean i thought that he did it
primarily for a defensive way he was
afraid of a knight coming to the e5
square and attacking some pawns
but are still very nice i know
and still the problem persists and uh
well
it's up to this is a problem that
pragnanda has to solve and while he's
thinking hard about how to solve this
problem well i just wanted to share with
you some more of our answers to our
caption competition where we are asking
everyone at home to caption this picture
of prague yesterday just as he realized
he'd blundered a czech mate and the best
caption wins one year subscription to
chess 24 premium and tonya hansen says
that moment when pragnanda realized he
didn't have any more room for the
trophies in his bedroom
must've been a long time ago yeah
daniel to dream says did i just see
simon riding a hippo
elizabeth rose says
ivanka's face when simon disses the
carrot card yeah it really is like oh
dear you do that simon
how very dare you i wouldn't i wouldn't
dare do that seriously you know
too much trouble here
i mean if prague really was worried
about his uh trophy cabinet he could
probably afford a new house by now of
all these winnings he's getting you know
so uh he doesn't have to worry about
that he's a whole house for his trophies
yeah so yeah
and uh if you two want to enter our
caption competition there's still time
then uh tweet your caption using the
hashtag jaztimes yes wow prag he really
hates castling
i know i've learned
two things from this game so far number
well from prag's play he doesn't like
castling and number two the dutch is
probably the best opening in the world
and you always get better positions
i already knew that yeah i did that's
not anything new but
i guess he's just playing like wait and
see but he's not really going to castle
king's side now and castle in queenside
also looks pretty scary so is he going
to leave that king there i mean there's
already a night jump which would stop
castling and
i i guess the reason this is not so bad
for prague and the knight does come in
is that you you're only attacking with
your knight at the moment but yeah black
wouldn't want to open up more more uh
more files to to really get through to
the king i was just wondering whether he
could kind of lock that knight out and
out of the game and uh
pick up an f-pawn but okay he's gone for
moving the night and insisting on a
night trade
i mean it's not a terrible strategy this
because if you can get rid of those
nights
maybe uh prague's idea of swapping his
bishop that night off earlier is just a
piece of genius because you know if you
can see the knights which are facing
each other if they can just literally be
removed from the board you'll be left
with one knight versus black's bishop
and black's bishop i have to say is
pretty bad because it's trapped in by
those pawns now which are fixed and
white's knight has a nice route into the
middle of the board so i don't maybe
this was just a very clever
a clever thing that prague did
positionally i mean or clearly
very positional idea i mean i don't know
interesting i think maybe critical here
would be for magnus to not allow this uh
exchange of knights and to just take a
step back uh he's lost time with the
black knight but at least he's uh as you
mentioned there simon he's
taken away the castling rights from the
white king and
it's hard to imagine white opening up
any lines towards the black king right
now just because black skin is super
safe the white king is actually on the
same flank and black does have this idea
later on pushing a pawn opening this
side up of the board up
and the queen side looks like blacks to
play on
yeah okay he goes for it immediately
what a move magnus is feeling really
brave right now
wow he doesn't even care about this
night trade he just pushes the pawn
allowing a capture of the knights i
guess his idea is that there's a pin
along this diagonal he wants to profit
from that and if there's a trade of
knights
okay first of all white tonight cannot
take the spawn you drop a rook in the
corner and actually this will end in
checkmate very shortly
and uh if instead you take with a pawn
does it's upon sacrifice for magnus does
he just want to push this pawn and try
and really open up lines if you can
imagine
okay this is helpful from white but if
you can imagine this bishop coming out
suddenly this bishop is on a great
diagonal this pawn is fixed in the white
camp
forever
i like it creativity creatively but uh
it feels a bit premature somehow from
magnus i don't see the refutation
immediately though i don't see how white
can
really punish this brave pawn move okay
well the bar has gone over
to prague side the team prague they must
be a little disappointed he's not going
to win the tournament but they must also
be proud of his achievements in the ftx
crypto cup and tanya in miami right now
is standing with his coach ramesh what's
happening tanya
one hundred percent kaya i think the way
prague has played has been phenomenal
and we've got the man who is known as
the father of modern indian chess he's
the one who's behind all the talents and
the big prodigies that we see coming out
this new wave of young chess players
from india ramesh thank you so much for
joining us thanks for the kind
introduction that was a bit exaggerated
i believe not at all
i have to ask you we've got the fourth
game going on now and the third game
didn't go according to prague's uh for
prague now coming into this final round
with the championship not at stake
what is the feeling does it take the
pressure off a bit
i think uh
we were not really playing for the
championship per se uh it's a fantastic
opportunity play against magnus and the
two coming in the final round under the
crucial circumstances
so it's a fantastic
situation for a youngster to
prove his metal that's what i see and so
far like
he has shown
many positives in his games he has
defended many very difficult situations
with less time on the clock against the
best place in the world so that's a
positive but
it's also a little bit worrying like in
some games he gets into trouble right
out of the item to the opening when the
theory even is out of theory
so that is probably one area we need to
work on the future now magnus mentioned
that prague has not played as well as he
has in the previous match especially in
the starting phase of the game like
you're mentioning right now
does that have something to do with
fatigue energy
i think like uh in some games he has
played extremely well uh i would say
probably like about under six to seven
out of ten games uh in the opening
phases uh we had a fantastic preparation
and some questions might have looked
dubious but we had thoroughly checked
with the computers and it was really
playable uh it's just that
when he forgets theory under pressure
sometimes he doesn't find the best move
over the board and then gets into
trouble and then
it looks like throughout the game has
been outplayed but that's not the case
but
probably like only in very few games he
has shown some
signs of nervousness right out of the
opening i would say but i don't think it
is to do with fatigue but it is quite
tiring to prepare for uh four games
every day with either color uh just
preparing for one game would have been
ideal but
preparing for both colors
and we also have to take into
consideration like situations like this
where we are trailing
what should be our approach so we should
have some backup plan as well so it
takes a lot of time and energy
and
just it is
seven matches so had it been nine it
would have been much tiring
right now ramesh we all remember the
time when
magnus had the first defeat against
prague earlier in the tour and now
prague is here playing outstanding chess
fighting for the championship as well
against magnus what do you think has
contributed to this growth that we've
seen in prague's performance over the
last year i think it is uh truck's
adaptability to play at this level uh
first of all like uh when he got a
chance to play in the tata steel masters
we were really apprehensive like in a
standard time control playing against
the best players when he has not had
much experience playing at this level so
uh he adapted quite well i believe and
he in the tata cell masters he had some
tough games in the middle of the
tournament but two once again he
recovered very well and managed to
defeat couple of very strong players and
since then he has grown from strength to
strength i would say and with each
tournament he is able to play these guys
and
many times he is able to beat these guys
in rapid tournament and so he's also
believing in himself in his capabilities
more and also we have been working a lot
in the opening preparation trying to
come up with new ideas because
most of the ideas are getting exhausted
very quickly
four games in a day so that's also a big
challenge but that also forces us to
work even more than before that's also
good for his game i believe
i want to ask you one thing now of
course like you said the players are
playing four games in euro requires a
lot of opening ideas and you also need
rest now while prague gets his rest do
you manage to get any sleep or are you
burning the night oil here no no uh
we realized like i'm not getting any
younger with the passage of time so i
also need to recharge my battery so i
can do my job efficiently so we both are
very particular about having a good
night's sleep irrespective of
how the games go we are very particular
about it and we have managed to
successfully do it under very difficult
circumstances also none of us will
complain lack of sleep during the
tournaments
right and finally ramesh the fourth game
is on i'm going to ask you what do you
think about the position has the opening
gone the way that you were expecting
magnus has played something out of the
blue d4 e64 before check was completely
unexpected but okay he has played a3 f3
so
we should be expect the unexpected i
believe but uh i think the opening went
well uh probably
when magnus played c5 that's when i
think prague's reaction of d5 probably
is not the best and after that i have
not uh seen the position so i don't know
really how it is currently but i think
probably d5 was not the best reaction
maybe long castle or d1 uh keep the
tension and then now i just think about
it even rook d1 short castle and then
try to play on the dark squares uh would
have been a better option because led if
i allowed him knight d to 95 with the
tempo threatening c 493 check it's very
difficult to handle over the body with
less time so i just hope for the best
hope for the best indeed and we've got
our fourth big game
running the man behind prague's success
and of course no matter what happens
he's a champion already thank you so
much ramesh for joining us
absolutely tanya the
super team pragnanda and ramesh they
have come up with so many good ideas in
this tournament and prague came so close
to winning the whole thing
we had a few moves in this game david
and the bar is over to prague's side
yeah we've had a few moves and
irrespective of where the bar sits it's
just chaotic on the board magnus really
doesn't care about pawns in this game uh
simon there just while ramesh was uh
being interviewed he mentioned magnus
really enjoying himself just throwing
pawns kind of going for the white king
this last couple of moves maybe we can
just jump into kind of recap what has
happened
and uh
here i mean i'm not even going to count
the pawns but we predicted this position
black trying to open up a diagonal for
his bishop maybe trying to open up a
file for his rook uh prague allowed this
to happen he brought his rook across and
after a trade of pawns magnus decided
okay i'm not gonna go from this angle
yet instead i'm gonna go directly for
the white king
he pushes forward and and after this
happened he brought his bishop out again
i'm slightly surprised he chose this
square yes he's attacking the rook but i
thought that it was part of white's plan
anyway to push the pawn forward just to
create some uh breathing space for his
king and now magnus is thinking
and uh okay finally i'll do a pawn count
white has seven pawns black has only
five so white's two pawns up
can he cling on that's the question
right now it's about this pawn maybe
black takes a step back
and the compensation lies in the fact
that this pawn is so strong white's king
is very very poorly placed and open
files for the black rook maybe a target
later who would you pick here guys and
why
very surprised about magnus's bishop
move as well there because um
you know the only
thing i can think he was you know trying
to do here with some kind of sacrifice
it's like bringing the rook in but it
doesn't look like any sacrifice is
working i i feel
um because you you you know you in a
position like this which is incredibly
sharp where your material down
and tempo losing time giving your
opponent more time is the key thing and
this pawn move
as you said is probably something that
white wants to play because now the king
can come forward it has another square
so i'm a little bit surprised by that
but saying all of that
i'm a great fan of giving up on my pawns
and getting the initiative you know i
love getting the initiative
and uh black has the initiative white's
king is misplaced
so practically speaking i think this is
probably easier for black to play black
can just try to get his rooks in the
game keep some pressure up i mean but so
hard to judge i mean if you didn't have
the computer assessment here you know
how how could you know know who's better
in this position now you're a bit of a
pawn grabber aren't you ivanka so are
you are you going to take the white
pieces what percentage do you believe
white is for winning this one for
winning this one oh
for winning this one this this one is a
bit murky actually i'm not that clear on
it i would say
thirty five percent for winning thirty
five years yeah because
white because i just i feel that this is
so messy because yeah the king is pretty
safe for now on the f2 square but if
that white knight is dislodged well then
it's not safe anymore like you guys
mentioned if a rook gets on the e line
and can come down to the e2 square that
is going to be curtains and black's pawn
on d3 is so strong
and there you go he puts a rook on the
open line
and how is black sorry how is white
going to even challenge that i mean you
have to step with the d-rook
on the board yeah because you can swap
brooks then
it will probably become very clear david
after the next couple of moves do you
think here because
white will either defend or or not i
mean i i wouldn't be surprised if the
white knight steps back now i'd be very
happy to get that white knight back in
the game it looks offside uh white's
king does have a nice square to hide on
white's king can head towards the right
magnus is not happy at all
i think he feels he's missed something
maybe he feels he should have used the
other black rook instead
just because that black rook in the
corner looks nice on an open file but
maybe it was more useful to keep two
rooks close together uh towards the
white king maybe he's annoyed but a
bishop move because he's allowed white
white's king to step up and he could
have had the same position here with the
white king not being able to allow the
white brooks to connect so you see the
white rooks now connecting he didn't
need to allow this so
little things like this would annoy nor
you wouldn't even and the problem is
when you sacrifice pawns and i get this
quite a lot or pieces you have to play
so accurately because
a lot of people assume it's much easier
to attack than defend that's not always
the case because if you don't keep the
energy up you'll just two pawns down and
you lose
so it's really easy to to you know let
any initiative just just blow away
um and that could also be something that
there's a danger here i mean i guess if
the knight comes back maybe we come in
with check but then the king just comes
out yeah and he's quite safe there right
so i mean yeah i don't really see
anything that black can try to be honest
uh let's jump in because there is this
massive threat that we mentioned
the black rook wants to come down with a
check this has been prevented by white
tonight stepping back covering this key
square
and as both of you mentioned black's
queen can now jump in with a check maybe
this is what magnus was relying upon but
now the white king just hides and it's
hiding behind four pawns
looks super safe and white remembers
those it's those two pawns up and magnus
just instead pushes his h-pawn yeah
i think there's a lot to be said as well
for this move you know just securing the
light squared bishop because whilst that
pawn on d3 exists then black will have
compensation for those two pawns because
there's really not that much that white
can do either you know white is just
really on just in reaction mode
yeah i mean it could also be the rook
thing you mentioned david because if you
had that rook next to the black king
that could do the swinger couldn't it
you know in these kind of positions that
might be why he was cursing himself that
he's put the wrong brook uh in the in
the middle of the board so you could
have used the other rook as you
mentioned and when the knight comes back
you give a check and either now or maybe
after this pawn push you could kind of
lift the rook across and start going for
the white king but instead we've seen a
few moves let's jump back to the game we
did see
just if we
rewind white offer a trade of rooks one
set of rooks are off the board but it
has come at the cost of this key pawn
on the edge and
magnus gobbles that one up willingly
with a check the white king steps back
so he's only one pawn down now magnuson
as ivanka mentioned this pawn is still
a bit of a
nuisance to deal with later on protected
by the black bishop also if the queen's
come off we've seen this happen now
three times to prague but
he might have rook and
knight and rook against
rook and bishop he's lost three in a row
of those types of end games if the
queen's come off will he lose a fourth
david do you know what he should do if
he gets that ending
tell us simon resigns
just resign
but i mean white's position though is
still so loose i mean is there a kind of
a move that he can play just to kind of
hold the thought
and i'm just kind of thinking building a
foundation in order to make progress so
i mean you highlighted the move h5h4
so maybe it's possible to step up with
the g pawn just i know it's ugly i know
it's and then step up with the king and
then use that as a way to propel forward
because you have to bear in mind
pragnanda is in a must-win situation
yeah
it doesn't look like the type of
position where you can kind of guarantee
that you're going to have a one-sided
game it's going to be
black trying to create things for the
near future it's just prague reacting so
it's about whether he can survive
yeah the
yeah the onslaught really and uh it's
looking really good for ali rezab russia
in game four against lavon aronia and if
he wins that game he will win that match
take three points and if russia does
that that means prague he will have to
take this to thai breaks and he will
have to win the tie breaks against
magnus to take second place to be the
runner-up in the tournament
and again i i'm sorry i was just going
to say hands it looks like he's he needs
to get drawn the last game but he looks
like he's struggling a bit right kya i
think they're just on the on the
according to the computer yeah so he won
a game today they also won a game they
are tied before this game for so close
to taking it to tie breaks and get that
point that i think everyone agrees he
deserves because there's been some good
chess from hans
just no points
so far and he played really well in the
first three games today maybe he should
have already already won this match
hands but i just looked over there
that's not looking good for the american
player
and maybe that's something he needs to
work on as well as the kind of the
mental side of things maybe also stamina
he's always starting well ending poorly
that's a big part of becoming a better
chess player
he can work on that as he gets a bit
older meanwhile the position here has
changed shavanka yeah i was just gonna
say it's swung
massively i think in black's favor i
mean because when you compare
the rook
and now look at what black is doing i
mean
i think it's going to be all about this
pawn on d3
yeah you think black's past porn is it's
ok i think it's such a good pawn i i
just
i mean you can't ever get rid of it and
whitens knight is always a great
defender white's queen is holding things
for now
can't black up the pressure there are
weaknesses in black cat in the black
camp as well
it looks good but maybe it's just visual
right now yeah
but we always have to remind ourselves
that
one man pragnanda is desperate he needs
to win yeah so he will probably be
taking a lot more risks and when i look
at the clock situation i see what a time
difference
pragnanda just over three and a half
minutes
meanwhile magnus while he's cruising
with 10 minutes
yeah it's been lightning fast from the
world number one
and it looks like he just wanted to
enjoy this game choosing a bit of an
unorthodox opening taking big chances
throwing pawns forward sacrificing
excuse me
are you okay simon oh i'm okay yeah yeah
just a
bit of coffee down the wrong way i'm
afraid so we've all been there yeah
all right i feel struggle for prague on
the board and the clock
ah okay well magnus carlsen enjoying
himself obviously in this game
he's already won the fdx crypto cup
prague he needs to come up with
something clever to win this game and
take it to
tie breaks
and the black bishop dropping back just
opening up the white uh the black queen
slightly more
magnus it feels like he's just sitting
there he is still a pawn down so i would
be worried if black went for something
too quick and it could backfire he's
just sitting on the position asking
prague
if he has any useful moves and maybe the
answer is no maybe white just has to sit
and wait as well
very hard for white to move the queen
very hard for white's knight to get back
in the game very hard for the white rook
which is passively defending upon
what do you think here will we just see
magnus take the practical approach and
uh kind of bully prague because it draws
i think you've got draw odds yeah i mean
it's very like so it's very hard to find
a plan for white i mean if white tries
to activate anything okay he's trying to
he weakens something now the back rank
is a little bit weak because the rook
was uh covering the back rank
um so it's a very good practical
decision isn't it just just to wait
until your opponent has to over
overpress and
i'd probably just put the rook down to
the bottom rank now seems to improve the
position somewhat and
then think about what to do you know
what to do next you know so that's my
strategy as well
just uh play the move
that wasn't that's now available to you
that wasn't available before yeah make
the white king feel a bit uncomfortable
if you come down
sneak in from behind with that black
rook and suddenly the white king is
maybe in a mating net so tactics will
work in your favor but there we see
magnus from behind his head just bobbing
along
i think he's listening to music now no
more podcasts yeah no more smiling he's
just shaking swaying
enjoying the position yeah
i'd also be tempted just to put the
bishop back to where the square it came
from
just kind of go yeah what's next well
exactly maybe prague's idea is to
sacrifice the exchange uh maybe white
just wants to get rid of that very
dangerous pawn that you were uh talking
about there i'm not sure that's a
winning attempt maybe it's just an
attempt to bail out and get the danger
off the position
but i wouldn't be surprised to see
magnus just kind of move his king up one
square just to a square it won't be
checked
you'd love those though
the little protrosian king moves
not sure it's that's a good strategy but
no i mean
again just why not improve your king
and uh see what white's trying to do
here because if white is trying to
sacrifice exchange prepare for it
there's not really much other point
behind that last move that white's
played really in this is something i
think again a lot of people may watch in
the commentary they they probably failed
to do a bit looking at their opponent's
last move
and just working out what they're trying
to do and just acting against their
opponents moves i think most people are
very tempted when they're playing chess
uh just from my experience of coaching
in the past to look at their plans a lot
more than their opponent's plans and if
you want to immediately try to improve
your own chess
just try to get into your opponent's
mind work out what they're trying to
play and try to stop their plans
you can win chess just by doing that and
i've noticed a lot of people jump up in
strength by
thinking thinking in that way as well
yeah and mine is thinking now for two
and a half minutes let's go to uh miami
where the chess fans are following the
action in the tournament
kaya chas has bought the world together
and has played such a big role in
changing people's lives now i've got
somebody very special with us who's been
doing a lot of work here in florida in
uh and otis is here with us to tell us
more about it absolutely thank you for
having me um so
we have 954 chess and we do a lot of
chess events uh in broward county which
is uh right next door to miami we also
do a lot of things in north miami as
well
we try to grow chess as much as possible
promote the game to as many people
and try to spread you know not only the
joy of chess but also the benefits of it
you know it can really improve
a lot of areas
in our society as far as
with children especially um especially
in uh
more
let's say uh impoverished communities
that
chess is
brought a lot of
good things to um you know less
fortunate children that
get to learn how to play
it's very good for their critical
thinking improving um just their social
skills and everything else it's a very
positive thing that i think helps a lot
of communities and you know we try to
promote that and help to uh to grow the
chess community at large and
bring exposure to chess in areas that
otherwise uh wouldn't uh consider that
as something you know an activity that
they enjoy so uh you know chess i think
is rich in culture and uh it's very
diverse and i think the more we try to
promote it uh in places where uh it's
not uh currently covered i think is a
great thing so i really enjoy what you
guys are doing here and i think it's
great for the chess community uh as well
as uh south florida so
it's also great what you're doing here
now tell me one thing that you know
we've got all these players from across
the world the biggest names in chess the
strongest grandmasters but also
these young upcoming talents who
probably going to be future world
champions what is it what does it mean
to miami and to your club and to the
kids there to watch these guys in action
uh well it's very inspiring you know
you got a lot of young talented players
from all over the world and
a lot of players
you know a lot of fans of the game not
even just players but fans of the game
really look up to these guys and
to see them here in person
it's an amazing thing and i think that a
lot of people uh enjoyed i think that
the fans of chess uh the children you
know that uh that play the game uh
really respect these guys really look up
to them and it's good to see them uh you
know in such a local venue
it's great and i hope that they have
more you know of these events
thank you so much autist for the amazing
work that you're doing for your
community and using chess as a tool to
make it a better place absolutely thank
you
back to you guys
absolutely we are so much cheering for
that
and uh alert of russia he has now won
his match against levon aronian three
points for him in that match means
prague he has to take this to thai race
and when the tie breaks to take second
place in the tournament
what is it looking like right now will
he be able to uh win this game craig i
mean first of all huge drama because
magnus has sacrificed the whole rook
um at first i thought it was a mouse
slip but no it looks like the world
champion uh he planned this all he's a
rook down in the current position but
look at that black pawn it's one square
away from promotion the white queen has
been forced back
to defend against it and it's just about
whether he can up the pressure now the
computer thinks it should be a draw but
for a human this is hard to evaluate
there are ways maybe you can get at the
white king you can try to use the black
queen to somehow force this uh this pawn
through to promotion
what do you guys think it's just pure
calculation here right yeah i mean i
like the move one
one of you suggested i can't remember if
it was but queen queen e5 looks uh maybe
actually david uh this move because also
friends bishop c2 in
some positions right so uh that that
looks like a very yeah clever idea
actually
yeah just to have a couple of multiple
threats there bishop c2 and just
bringing the queen in yeah um are both
threats are very scary at least um how
does white guard against this you have
to drop a rook back i guess uh-huh okay
maybe this is the only way otherwise i
mean this is just a winning threat so i
guess the rook drops back
right and
at least this way you can capture and
play open up the white king maybe uh
worst case scenario at least here white
would be out of danger
black would be playing for the draw i
just have a sneaky feeling that it might
uh just because the evaluation bar says
0.0 the best player might end up
something like this the queen comes in
the rook moves somewhere across and then
black opens up the white king
and eventually we might just see the
position repeat itself with some kind of
draw although here it's still a bit
scary for white with the black bishop
lurking
and yeah it's still super complicated
but magnus has this choice to make if we
go back to the current position does he
try this idea
ivanka you were mentioning maybe queen
the queen can also come to g3
good sneaking from this angle try to
deliver a nasty check if the white rook
guards against that check
uh by bringing itself across maybe now
you could
now you do that now that the h3 and uh
yeah this is messy stuff and i think
here like probably
unless the king is running
which it may well be but
you've got bishop d3 haven't you yeah
but that doesn't work
just just thought it was a move but
maybe the king runs away maybe bishop c2
though but maybe the queen can just
carry on checking her so it's so
complicated let's just like it should be
a draw here let magnus work it out no
that's his job isn't it there's no way
actually for white's king to run away so
you just kind of force the draw the
position repeats itself and
magnus he has this one in his pocket it
looks like he can force the drawing
immediately with this uh idea from
ivanka bringing the queen to the square
but maybe he's looking for more it looks
like black is so close to winning
because this pawn is only one move away
but maybe the white queen just guards it
sufficiently
and yeah magnus he can't take too many
risks he's a rook down after all uh he
does drop his queen back and now we're
expecting the white rook to come
to the bottom of the board there we go
prague plays it instantly he was
calculating in magnus's time and at
least this rook now um it did kind of
cost the black pawn it's life and magnus
he's fighting for a draw white isn't
pawn up
uh still some life left in the game
and the evaluation bar reacts magnus
didn't go for the white king when he
could have done he could have forced the
draw immediately and look at this the
computer finds a really sneaky move to
press the advantage white's queen can
actually kick away this bishop from its
great outpost now just by stepping
forward uh queen d2 according to the
stop fish and if the bishop moves then
happy times it cannot take this pawn due
to a nasty double attack a check and you
pick up the bishop on the next man of
course prague played it and he played it
wow i mean if there's one move
there's no perpetual here by oh you got
f4 i was thinking black can try checking
multiple times but it doesn't work um
and this time you can block yeah yeah
magnus is in trouble yeah suddenly we
might see playoffs in this match yeah
prague could still fight for second
place
wow what's a turnaround magnus had the
draw in his pocket but he played on and
now fighting for his life
yeah and he's he's missed a couple of
moves hasn't he here i mean he this this
bishop in he played very quickly but
it's just a just a blunder
because now he's going to move the
bishop again and he's lost some
important tempo and he's porn down
um
yeah yeah i think in his mind he was
just thinking
okay just it's gonna be a draw no matter
what i do yup he just took his eye off
the ball for one second and suddenly
prague seized the opportunity
and we just actually saw a slight tell
from the world champion that he's
frustrated and now we can clearly see it
there because you just saw him say
what am i gonna do now i mean how could
this happen
and uh
goodness me what a turnaround i mean it
just looked like magnus was playing
superb chess and now he's fighting for
his life and there we can see that he's
considering putting his bishop on the f1
square but then he kind of took it back
he's not sure about that i mean is the
bishop safe on that square the bishop
might get trapped there yeah the white
king could have just moved across and
dangerous times for this black bishop
changing his mind magnus he's down to
under two minutes
no longer trusting his instincts after
some some kind of mistakes there he's
probably got to put it near his king
just to keep it safe back where it came
from
yeah two big moves as well and he could
have opened up the white king by pushing
his h-pawn for example just just trying
to open up some lines but he he didn't
do that and now uh
these two tempos should cost him the
game they're both now time-wise a minute
and a half left so they're gonna have to
speed up and look at look at his body
language he's so frustrated right he
nearly threw the mouse there it looked
like he wanted to kind of hit something
or smash something but okay he's
refocused now
magnus
he could still defend this if he's uh
accurate and a bit lucky yeah but the
white knight is going to finally get
back in the game the white knight has
been so far detached from its own king
from any defense from any real action
for the whole game
but now
prague he's got queen a knight against
queen of bishop not rook a knight
against rick and bishop and uh here it's
kind of a different assortment the queen
and knight usually work better together
in tandem
than the queen of bishop having an extra
pawn also helps
and uh the world champion now under one
minute
this is the last game now going on in
the arena it's a win for liam lee
against hans niemann in that final rapid
game that means liam wins to take all
three points it ends up with zero points
in the tournament for hans niemann but
he has a lot of new fans no doubt about
it and he's played some great chess as
well
but zero points for the american this
one will be the final rapid game in the
fdx crypto cup question is
will we see blitz tie breaks or will it
be over after this game
yeah that is a big question i think we
might be in for more chess today right
uh if pragnando can organize his pieces
correctly
one move that screams out to be played
is just centralizing the white knight
bringing it back into the action
uh what else could you consider here
maybe you could step a pawn forward to
attack the black queen
prague goes for a more aggressive
approach he brings his queen forward to
attack harry the h-born over the black
king not safe anymore no certainly not
safe
and uh well how is black going to even
defend that born i mean he has to step
forward and give a check
but then he leaves his king
all abandoned yeah maybe he could push
this pawn
and uh just trying to open up the white
king even if it costs you a second pawn
here i mean this is the move he he
should have played without moving the
bishop i'm sure you know he had to open
up the white king with this little lever
uh and he missed his opportunity now the
knight comes in prague is just like so
so good at not being scared of moose and
uh the white king switches over is there
any
any hope here i mean the white king's a
little bit a little bit weak isn't it
but is it weak enough you need some kind
of miraculous perpetual check where
white skin can't escape where you can
repeat the position three times but this
last move so clever from the white king
if the white king had taken this pawn
actually we've seen a turnaround
and uh magnus would have won because
there would have been a nasty bishop
check look at the queens the tension
between them magnus under 20 seconds as
well if you take the white knight the
black bishop would have fallen
so now two pawns up for prague
where's the king running to can you just
run up the board got to go forward so i
guess it'd be a draw say he must go up
the board only choice now yeah go on an
odyssey start attacking some pieces
let the king become the hunter
yeah he might as well step forward you
can always repeat the position
afterwards
and uh magnus is ready for a pre-move
there he's ready to check that white
king
okay still some chance for black if
prague chooses the wrong square
king i mean the white king is still
exposed uh obviously if the queen's ever
come off it's completely game over but
the you know that king is exposed yeah
so knight and bishop come off that's
also game over yeah this check is very
annoying for prague you can't step
forward now towards the center
you've got to watch out for some checks
some skewers
he's running away again
maybe this is clever he's done a little
kind of triangle maneuver and now the
black queen is further away from the
square she wanted to use earlier
and yeah not easy he's playing
confidently prague as well i mean he's
playing his moves quickly now and uh but
he's got to get out of this little
series of checks at the moment
he's doing very well
at forcing uh the queen away from the
king but the black queen still has a lot
of squares he's using every square
possible here prague and at least now
the checks will dry up the white queen
is ready to come back to her king's
defense and block any remaining checks
so magnus gives up on that idea
just gets his bishop to safety
can white's queen start giving some
checks now can the white knight jump
back
to a better square
prague
ever since he was gifted this
opportunity again perfect technique yep
definitely and uh but it's still a
question of getting that king to safety
and he retreats his queen
yeah good choice of square
the white queen guards the dark squares
so the white king will have some safety
potentially
the black bishop just doesn't have a
safe kind of
outpost to sit on
well he's got a threat now
you know threaten checkmate with this
bishop the black queen wants to swing
the whole way across to the g2 the light
square near the white king checkmate
actually yeah not easy to defend you
have to kind of
yourself that's great defense because
also now white is threatening to
exchange off queens as well so
yeah
uh white queen wants to firstly attack
the black bishop but also go to the h2
square in front of the white king
that's a check and you hit the black
queen yeah as you mentioned simon quinn
a queenless endgame it's an easy win for
white
so magnus has to stop that idea
okay but but now uh
the bishop and the queen are in a pickle
they're tied up together and of course
you can't step back to give a check
because the queen would block it so okay
now's the chance to have a you've got a
free move
now is the
moment to move the night friend check
mate why not exactly yeah
stop going checks and we do have a
result pragnanda has taken it to
tybridge wow
impressive oh imagine if uh this would
have meant he uh
still had a chance to win the fdx crypto
cup he still has a chance now to take
second player plays though pragnanda
a massive win against the world not